hello
my name is Markiplier and welcome to
Amanda the adventurer brought to you
live from Markiplier HQ which means that
I
want to do a live stream and play this
game how are you how is everybody out
there it's good to see you I am uh a
little bit tired but funny stories
um
I'll get to that in a second hello
hello
everybody
welcome welcome welcome
uh so funny story is uh I I don't know
how but I think I broke my nose again
um it's like just before I started this
live stream I was like man my nose hurts
and then I looked at myself in the
camera and I was like man oh am I like
not getting enough sleep I got these
dark circles under my eyes
um I think I broke my nose not 100 sure
how I did that
I um I've been doing that with more
rabid frequency as of late so I've not
been able to keep up with my own uh
solid bones but my bones seem to be
extra fragile lately
I don't think it's broken broken but I
think it might be maybe look
you can see like a little red spot and
then my eyes
it's like I have some kind of
like I swear I've been getting better
sleep I haven't been getting the
greatest sleep in the world but um
I think I broke my nose again I'm not
Emerson sure why I don't know what I did
and it's a little bit sore right now
so either I rubbed my face really hard
or
um I wash my face you know like how men
do and they just slap their hands with
water as hard as possible I think that
might have been what I did
um but regardless I'm gonna persevere
ooh ow it hurts so badly I need all the
pity points possible to be able to get
through this game it's gonna be so hard
oh the orange juice Journey that it is I
just feel oh man oh I'm gonna need all
your your liking subscribes God oh man
every like And subscribe is one Booboo
kiss right on my uh my broken nose man
it sounds different when I'm right up
close to it versus just slightly far
away from it
um I just made a movie well I haven't
made it yet I still gotta edit it so I'm
in the process I'm in the process of
editing it right now
um but so far so good that's all I can
say about it for now I'm working on it
if you don't know what I'm talking about
that's that thing that I was punching
back into place
I don't know if punching myself in the
nose to get it back into place is the
best idea you've ever come up with but
it might not be the worst so uh keep it
up was I talking about you may be you
may be completely forget about what I
was doing
huh play it I would play it in a second
I'll get to it
what if I just want to enjoy the menu
screen everyone skips over the menu
screen so quickly they don't even pay
attention to all the art and craft that
was put into the menu screen
you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna skip right over this I
can't believe you I can't believe you
um
feature length why does everyone think
it's a short film I wouldn't have been
gone for uh three months if it was just
a short film if you guys think that I
can't do a short film in three months or
if you think it takes me three months to
make a short film no it's feature length
it's meant for theaters you dummy how
many times I gotta say that oh you made
a short film [__] Milford of Milford
Wilford mother loving Wharf stash was a
short film and we filmed that in three
days I edited it in four so it's just
like that's a short film
I can be there will it be in theaters
what did I just say
what did I just say I said that
it's a movie
is my film about iron lung it's like
it's literally called iron have you not
seen the trailer with the title how many
times I got why so long I don't know I
didn't start movies
but I am going to finish it
but will it be in theaters though yeah
right yeah right
yeah yeah I'm streaming uh so funny
story right before I started streaming I
think I broke my nose again
um
I don't know how but it's a little sore
and it's it's it's definitely I think I
definitely have like a some slight black
eye going on and there's definitely a
red spot on my nose I don't know what I
did
as far as I know I was just living life
just going about my day we're recording
some go my favorite sports team and then
you know uh I came home and I did some
chores and I was doing some editing and
then all of a sudden I I was like I'm
gonna go stream and then all of a sudden
looks like ow my nose kind of hurts I
don't know what I did
I have no idea maybe my head's gonna
explode he might be right about that
yeah
please put my hair up nah I don't feel
like it you don't tell me what to do and
no matter how nicely you ask third
time's the charm I think this is
actually the fourth time
fourth time ever played this
but other than that life is going well
um I have wonderful news I have
wonderful news I uh forget what I was
gonna say but the news was wonderful as
soon as I remember it I will tell you
exactly what that news was
my movie about a steel liver
that's funny
now that's funny right there
now that's funny noise is too loud what
do you mean noises too loud
it couldn't possibly be too loud
it couldn't possibly be
is it too loud
I'll play the game when I'm damn good
and ready
you're not gonna miss out on this
beautiful menu screen I don't care how
long we gotta talk about the my life
we're gonna look at
has it always been doing that
I'm not 100 sure I have so much to catch
up on and I'm gonna catch up on it
whether you like it or not
whether you like it or not I run this
stream here and I run it with an Iron
Fist and a clenched anus and those two
things in combination are going to make
a great viewing experience for you but
you have to be patient
just like with everything else in my
life I go at it with whatever the first
thing I said was in a clenched anus
that's the secret to success everyone
you want to be a YouTuber you got to
clench your anus as hard as possible and
then go through life and that's all you
got to it everyone walk around with
their soft angels
anyway
um
well there was some important stuff
there were so many things that I needed
to catch up on and tell you about and
just like various other things that were
like really really important
that I I just cannot remember it
where's chica yeah who knows
it's not loud just turn your volume down
I yeah I don't I don't think people
understand that they have a volume knob
anymore
I don't think that people understand
that that just exists in life you can
you can adjust the volume as much as
possible
um and then it'll be up to your own
destiny of whatever your viewing
experience would be
show chica I don't know where to I don't
know where chica is I don't know where
chica is chica's not here
how are you feeling thank you someone
finally asked me a nice question about
myself I'm feeling great I finally got
back home I finally got a refill of my
ADHD medication and I finally had a very
seamless experience in getting it
mwah wonderful incredible I don't know
if you
I know it doesn't seem like it right now
but look I've got a lot of pent up
energy
that I need to get out one way or
another
no I don't know how I broke my nose I
don't I don't even know if I broke my
nose like it looks like it's broken a
bit like I I don't I don't know what I
did what could I possibly done that
would break my nose because I did this
at the beginning of filming and that had
a clear-cut explanation for it I don't
know what I did here
like how did I was just gearing up to do
a stream and then all of a sudden I was
like ow I don't know what happened
live or Premiere this is live do you
think that I do you think that I edited
this and then put it up without even
thinking about what I was gonna do no I
only do that on live streams where I
just go live and I have no idea what I'm
doing
play the game I will the more people ask
me to play the game the less game I'm
gonna play I'm gonna sit here and look
at this menu screen and I'm gonna get
every bit of content out of this we're
gonna do a four hour video essay on the
breakdown of the scuffs on the side oh
actually I just realized here's some
deep lore these are actually stickers
you can tell that they've been ripped
off at some point why
aliens or whatever the other cursed lore
of this is it might have been an
appearance of Five Nights at Freddy's
because this could be a Bonnie sticker
and this could be a a mangle sticker and
this one
that's clearly a pizza representing
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza place which is
actually the second restaurant that was
ever opened uh it all comes back to FNAF
always does fine
I'm gonna do this
dear Riley if you're reading this it
means you won't see me again unless it's
in the next life I wish I could have
told you everything I don't know how
much time I have and there's still so
much I have to do before I'm gone
this letter serves two purposes to say
goodbye and the bequeath you to you my
house in kensdale
this next part may be a mistake and
God's forgive me if it is when you
settle in there's something in the attic
I need to pass on to you
look for a tape but know that once you
watch it there's no turning back stay
safe my dear with you always on Kate
well [__] you too Aunt Kate
I don't care who you what kind of loving
aunt is gonna bequeath
accursed tape to their
family member
what kind of excuse is that this game
uses an auto save feature okay
why is this so oh my God
uh input please down please
oh
that's no better what in the logarithmic
hell
yeah okay
even this is this five
this is five
what
how is that far
how is this is this one
is this any different
what did I do
what did I do to dessert this is one
how do you mess that up
how do you all right it's fine I'll deal
with it hello
oh interesting ah
wow that's slow okay
um
[Music]
okay
I did it all right well I did it glad I
did that what about you
you not nothing
what about you
for you something
aha
oh
okay
I'll never get this puzzle right
I'm sorry
someone's squonking over there
just do the tip just do the tape
oh just do the tape oh someone just
wants me to speed through oh someone
wants me to just go through
fruit fruit
who would I be if I didn't pick up the
banana
yeah hey get in there you'll I could get
it there you go
Wham
hey
banana you get back in there
wow I am very weak
oh my God
wow because I put my sensitivity down
girl
well we're gonna be here a while
excuse me
oh
nope
I just don't want to work wow
all right okay
damn it
God damn it
yeah
why is it so hard
can it even go in there
what are you resting on
hmm
it's not gonna beat me guys I think
there might be an in whoa okay
I think there might be an invisible wall
ah there's an invisible wall
but man oh no
well that was anti-climactic all right
what else we got
hello
is that supposed to be there is that a
bonus fruit is this a peach
why is there a peach
this new fruit
this is fruit too I swear that wasn't
there before
man the mystery is really getting thick
guys
I need the pan
ride of course
because the pan goes in the oven
[Music]
it's beautiful it's a little quiet
ER
hmm
you want to run that by me again champ
all right well
I don't think I can solve this mystery
nine one one
all right so we got a series of puzzles
here that are very clearly uh
uh meant to be solved it's how many
goddamn combination locks are you gonna
have in here
who spilled
what oh hi thank you but that's not my
favorite flower
wait a minute what
I'm sorry what did you just say to me
how dare you talk to me like that hi on
Kate thank you so much for the roller
skates dad and I went skating at the
lake yesterday he fell down but don't
tell him I told you that can't wait to
see you at summer vacation love Riley
okay well yeah I've been cursed a lot I
ain't reading that
no I'm not reading any of that when did
it change when did you whatever shut up
oh that's the note
okay well I don't understand what you
want
and I don't understand what you are
well this is horrible
oh
oh do not get blah bought wet
my God okay
uh
oh
interesting
in the kitchen well this couldn't
possibly be the answer so I don't know
what that's about
um well I'm wait a minute
it's a clue
oh it's another puzzle again
how many goddamn puzzles are in this I
thought it was going to be a clue to the
grandfather clock that I was going to be
able to solve everything but now I'm
just stuck in my stupid when did you
come from
I'm sorry what are you talking about
huh all right whatever
okay all right well I'm stumped so I
think that's gonna be it for Amanda the
adventure from me uh great game really
solid experience
um yeah I had a blast I I think
everybody at home you had a great time
uh so thank you so much for watching uh
remember to like uh comment share
subscribe
and uh no I don't know what you mean by
tape I I think that this really
showcases that when you make a game uh
that can be fully released it's
it really does bring about a a new sense
of uh life to the uh franchise I think
it's gonna be I think it's gonna be all
right anyway there you go
whatever you guys in your anti-fun
Hey look
hi I'm Willy foreign
what's your favorite kind of pie
oh man
um I like pumpkin
but I don't know if you're gonna let me
type it
whoa
no that sounds delicious uh-huh today
we're going to make an apple pie first
we need to cut the apples hmm do you
know what we can use to cut the apples
a knife good job thanks we can use a
sharp knife yeah I don't think we're
supposed to do that by ourselves
it's always good to be brave when you're
by yourself yeah cheers
that doesn't seem safe
almost everything we need to make our
pie we just need some sugar hmm do you
know where we keep the sugar is it in
the pantry the refrigerator or the sink
oh
where's your pantry I don't see a pantry
here I see cupboards
um
nope try again oh man I really don't you
want to help me I don't know where your
pantry is or if you're talking about the
cupboards you should have said that
that's on you and not on me that you
don't know the difference between a
pantry and your cupboards this is ones
for cup it's cup boards but the other is
a sink in a fridge
so where's the sugar again this doesn't
help me help you because you don't know
what a pantry is you declare the options
and the pantry ain't in this vicinity if
you wanted me to go to The Pantry
where's where's your little broom closet
that has your food in it because that's
what I'm looking for you're telling me
that it's in the highest cupboard up
there is that what you're telling me
the pie this is a lie now the apples and
cinnamon no
no okay it's time to bake a pie first
preheat the oven to 425. I don't think
we should be using the oven by ourselves
we should always ask a parent to help
I'm not sure where they are right now
we're lying our own Willie
first preheat the oven to 425 degrees
then put the apples into the pie tin now
put it in the oven and bake it for 40
minutes
our pie is ready wow I can't wait to eat
it Willy
okay well you know wooly you knew what
hey
Willie you knew what you were signing up
for when you came to the whole let's
have a pie meeting oh shhh hey
hey I was on the right track from the
get-go give me
let me put a banana in your oven
let me put a banana pie get out of here
no it's stuck
it's stuck in
no no no no
no no
no
there we go
oh yeah perfect no
no
ah Wham what
[Music]
you suck
whatever nerd you know
you know what stupid
oh wait I forgot the most important step
I need a sharp knife
where is it
important
this seems important
seems very important
uh you want this
sorry
no is it not done growing
oh okay um
lamp
get some light
so uh where can I get a knife
knife
safe
where
would a knife be and why aren't you
taking this
you took the other one why would you not
get this one was it not good enough for
you
were you even talking to me before
huh
no mushroom
no they're not good enough for you
is that not good enough for you
it's fine it's got to be a knife around
here somewhere everyone hold on while I
slowly descend into madness
all right
no
no no
God damn it
I hate you
oh all right so there's got to be a
knife around here somewhere there's
there's a there's I do you saying I
don't need a knife that was in the
instructions it was you need a sharp
knife you have to cut up your Apple you
make it into a pie and then you put it
in the oven
425 for 40 minutes
that's what it said that was the
instructions if the if this game doesn't
need me to get a knife then it shouldn't
have said to get a knife
there's a knife in here somewhere and
I'm gonna get it because that's what the
video instructed me to do
you get a knife you cut the apple and I
don't care if we stay here all night
I'm doing as instructed because I follow
the rules
that's what I do
see it don't make sense it don't it
don't make no sense here can you cut
this for me I need an adult
anybody cut see it doesn't make sense it
just see it just don't make sense how
could you how could you possibly make an
apple pie
oh
[Music]
well that's just silly
I'm putting a banana in it
when I'm putting a goddamn banana in
this
girl what you say bam
[Music]
I swear if I put this tape in there and
it doesn't have the most explicit
instructions possible that I'm supposed
to follow to the letter I'm gonna lose
it and then I'm gonna go on a killing
spree like that's just the only way
about it there's nothing else to do
all right Amanda listen I've had just
about enough of your [__] friends I'm
Amanda and I'm woolly
we're kind of open-ended question is
that wait I like that there are so many
minutes first I need to go to the store
to buy them a card
tell where the store is CBF
CBF
c b
f what's with the uh
what's with the outlines what I don't
even remember what was there that's not
this door silly
type of store
yeah it's the breads store good job
let's go to the store let's pick out a
card my friend helped me when I was sad
what kind of card should I send them
1503.25
[Applause]
one thousand
five hundred and three and 25 cents
that's how I'm gonna remember that we
got CBF and then 1503.25
what did you ask me to do I don't even
remember do you think that's what they
need I don't remember what they need
what were you talking about
1503.25 great I found the perfect card
time for the next series I don't
remember friends do nice things
I want to get my friend a special treat
can I have a special treat
where can I buy a treat from my friend I
mean at the corner store technically
speaking
wow
wow I hope all the trees are still by
the time we get there can you show me
where to go
job let's go get that tree
foreign
[Music]
everything smells so good I want to buy
my friends
buy my friend some cookies can you show
me where the cookies are well I mean
technically yeah of course I could I
don't think I don't think my friend will
like that what kind of friend doesn't
like cake I can't mail that to my friend
oh
I get it
[Music]
I'll take friend they live pretty far
from me so we need to mail it wow it's
getting late most of the stores are
closed we probably can't send that now I
have to send this to my friend it's time
to go to the Post Office let's send this
package to my friend their name is
wait
I don't remember
can you can you help me we can come back
tomorrow how would I know I don't have
to send that now no I have to
have to mark no that's not my friend's
name you're damn right all right your
friend what about you have to know their
name oh I don't know who you're talking
about
[Music]
um uh oh
[Applause]
I hope she likes the cookies
[Music]
but also
what
happened
[Music]
ham Elm
you
what [__] oh three two five
all right fine but at the same time
why won't you accept this
ham Elm
ham
um
h
that's not an H
whoa what
what the frick what in the what in the
frick
anyone else see that
you know I'll see that scurrying across
the way
just me
wait a minute
symbols on them
so what would your favorite well
uh no
oh God
okay I'll get that letter
okay we got oh
foreign
there's got to be some other deeper
level of secret to all this because it's
not going to be just a hand holding
going one at a time is it
is it
it's probably not but it probably also
is oh it's you hey whatever you do
donuts
oh god oh no Lily had an accident
an accident is when something bad
happens but it's not anybody's fault
accidents can happen in your house at
school at the playground you can get
hurt almost everywhere
at 3 45 this afternoon we were playing
and Woolly tripped and fell I I didn't
where on woolly does it look like he got
hurt man that was the most subtle thing
I've ever seen at 3 40 five
uh
full face that part of Willy looks fine
but God don't type it ah don't type it
oh God don't type it
hurry up he's hurt fine all right
that's right Lily hurt his need who can
help when you are hurting
oh
who can help when I'm hurting I I I
don't I don't know I don't know who can
help whatever I don't what
uh
oh man ah Satan
E I don't think they can help
[Laughter]
are you sure
are you sure I don't know about that
um
mother
don't you want to help Willie
you're almost there I'm wasting my time
and I'm running out of fishing
oh oh okay gotcha
[Music]
which room should we go into to find the
right doctor to help wooly
hey it's 6 20. well not really it's
actually this would be
that would be over there so it's like I
don't know what am I doing it's knee
um
I don't think that doctor can help
Willie are you sure Willy's in a lot of
pain uh-huh please help me get to the
right doctor
okay we gotta remember 345 and 6 20.
Amanda this is really hard and 22.50
what is the doctor
check wooley's injury the heart monitor
the X-ray machine or the scale cop on
the scale Big Buddy no silly
what is on the scale Big Buddy
what what is on the scale
all right so we need to know 345 620 and
then 22.50 so 345 620 and 22.50 got it
I'm scared what should we use
I die
oh
all right so there's got to be something
to do with these times right
[Music]
2001 Hamilton entertainment two zero
zero two thousand one it's a year it was
a really tough one okay so we got 345
six
twenty and uh 750. you shut up
what about you
are you gonna shut up
so this one looked like the 620 one
well that's pretty good
okay but what about this one it doesn't
have any other
22.50
that would be
that'd be
50.
which would have both
but it would be
but it would but it would be but but it
would be but but it but but
that's what it would be
but it would be that
if it was 22.50
then
everyone back up my brain is swelling my
wrinkles are deepening
my I don't know what and never mind uh
there's no K here never mind my wrinkles
are smoothing everyone please help me
I'm I'm just getting unbelievably smooth
brained okay so the answer
they want me to think that it's easy huh
well
let's try 22.50
all right well that didn't work
I guess I'll do 345 then
ah
I see sounds pretty good right I'm
pretty smart
yeah I'm pretty good
pretty good
again
oh oh
ah
damn it all right so that was it oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
huh
all right fine
okay so it's got to be 5 15 in this last
one right
unless
unless it's so obvious
because
five fifth what
huh
how long has that been there
I've been there this whole time
I have no idea
ah whoa
tick tock tick tock I've no idea what
that means hey whoa my hand it's in my
hand peach butt it's in my hand
and it's in that hand
uh
hahaha
ah
God damn I am unbelievably smart I am
unfathomably smart I am
without a doubt one of the smartest
smarts
oh
safe eight two six
well I couldn't possibly understand what
this goes to who knows
all right
so you're gonna tell me this this is
eight two six
[Music]
now see this is my one of those things
where it's so it's so pointed at one
thing that I'm like are you sure it
means that or are you pointing generally
over this way
safe a two two six
hey wait a minute
safe
eight two six
eight two
six
of course
well I thought that would be an okay all
right well never mind then
I was wrong
I'll just remember it everything rots
why is that the moral
safe
eight two six
safe eight two six
I'm Amanda and I'm woolly
such a nice day for a picnic uh-huh
what's your favorite food to eat
look um Amanda I'm not gonna lie to you
oh I don't like that at all
uh Amanda what's that smell
I've never smelled anything like that
they don't know Willy
bad smell what do you think is making
that bad smell well it might be your
attitude because I wasn't even telling
you food I was saying that I've never
actually had an opportunity to go on a
picnic I've never done the thing where
you have a blanket and you put out a
basket and you bring some foods because
I I just never have had that in my life
and you know I don't know if you're
judging me for that but just because I
haven't had the privilege to be able to
do that once in my life or had anyone to
share that experience with it's not like
I if I ask someone I'm pretty sure I
could go it's just like I've never had
like such a such a yearning for such an
adventurous moment in my life and that's
not for you to judge
like how dare you
whatever anyways
uh what was the question
um
both is it wooly
woolly are you making that smell
you you're right what was I right
because it's running
this tree stump is riding too do you
know why
things rot but they are not alive
anymore
do you know what the opposite of alive
is
look at the tree stump if it's not alive
what is it
I don't think we should be talking about
this
are you afraid to think about it that's
right
wow
dead is opposite of alive
can die if they don't get enough light
or water or if they get a disease let's
go back to our nice picnic
animals can die in different ways too
look at poor Mr Fox he is dead and body
what do you think killed him the gun the
knife or the poisonous berries on this
bush well it's kind of hard to tell from
this resolution but I'm thinking that
the culprits right is it right here
uh the knife that was it I don't know
why there's a gun and just check how
massive this gun is
this gun is like a 220 caliber gun no it
wasn't that look at his bunny tough he's
silly what killed him I don't know you
did you woolly
wouldn't it be nice if he could tell us
Mr Fox what made you die
it was the ugly old bear trap Mr Fox
didn't even know what got him until it
was too late great Amanda this has gone
too far I don't like this we thought
a riding sandwich a rotten tree stump
and cilio riding Mr Fox
but it feels far away Amanda nothing is
rotten here what do you think do you
think that everything rots of course not
a man I'm not asking you answer my
question you don't have to answer that
I don't even know how I'm answering this
in the first place
um
but this I thought it was a yes or no
question you give me uh Riley why won't
you answer my question
oh
[Music]
oh I don't remember I literally don't
remember what you what it what what whoa
friend
see I don't really remember what
it the question was
uh
I think it might be too late maybe
mayhaps absolutely what was that
oh
that's a problem
[Music]
all right
haha
yeah
okay
so
what I'm to glean from this hey a safe
well if only I had a code
wait
I know what I'm doing oh
all right
well
now we're on to something
hi
what is your favorite color is it yellow
it's yellow isn't it
your favorite color is yellow
with 24.
oh you you thought you could hide from
me
but the truth was
you can only hide from yourself
uh we can't read this well this is
peculiar
where is it
who's got it where is it where is it
I know what this is
I don't know what this is too
this is going right there
nice all right it's got to be around
here somewhere it's around here
somewhere
someone's hiding it from me and I ain't
about that
you thought you could hide from me well
that just confirms it
what was it
well that just confirms for me what I
already knew
is this your favorite color thank you
that's my favorite flower oh cool I got
a surprise
surprise that you'll have
[Music]
a half
oh okay I thought
[Laughter]
that was gonna be so much worse than
that oh okay all right thank you for
that that's that's lovely thank you I
appreciate that that's that's really
nice
that's really something special
um so what happens if I do this sooner
wait you're already at the time here no
3 45 and then 6 20.
oh
okay well that didn't work it probably
needs the other one to be out here
before that'll happen
so I have a tape I open this safe I took
everything out of here
that's off banana is a no-go
so why is this off to the side
this must also be something special
because it was off to the side in some
way
and that means something in this game
apparently if it's hidden around a
corner that means it's more important
than the other things that were there
right
same with you
I have to be another meaning
because if there's another meaning that
means there's another secret to uncover
back there
okay I'm gonna find out what this uh
what this orange tape is
where's the birthday girl oh usually my
mom holds my treat money
well come on Lauren we have a special
surprise write that down write that down
I can't write that down who's ready for
ice cream and cake she's busy with her
best friend
is that showing 24 7. it's like she
didn't even hear me and we need to talk
about some new TV rules
you know what hold on let me try I want
to I want to capture the big surprise on
video Lauren honey
we got cake and ice cream we got your
favorite and then chocolate chip come on
baby we can watch Amanda another time
Lauren are you okay
Lauren
Lauren I love mint chocolate chip
hmm interesting the plot thickens
something else is happening here so mint
chocolate chip
you
thought I saw something you love mint
chocolate chip which has got to be
a clue wait a minute
don't that kind of look like Amanda the
adventurer
Dash is
there's got to be something about that
that is important
because in the original man of the
adventure many things had to be done
before you would even get into the other
parts of it before otherwise you would
miss your chance right
man I can really squeeze back here
why
that's bizarre
also what do you do with the mushrooms
you could do with the mouse
the mushroom
s
okay
I'm going in
because I have a pause button now
I don't know what the what would that
even do
oh
fascinating
why are you able to do that
huh
interesting
I'm Amanda and I'm woolly today we're
going to make an apple pie my favorite
is peach
oh Peach
that sounds delicious today we're going
to make an apple pie all right first we
need to cut the apples hmm do you know
what
but we can use to cut the apples
oh God
a gun on you can't use that
right uh
we can't use that
good job we can use a sharp knife wait
oh boy
but it's not it said there was something
about that
it was something about that
it said something there was like the
oven on fire
so I'm guessing
how do I how do I make oven on fire
how do I make oven on fire it was oven
on whoa what the oh oh oh oh oh oh
whoa wait whoa whoa way whoa whoa whoa
wait a minute
what
[Music]
cheese
Wham nope almost so close Wham
nope come on now
ah perfect oh
that was such an instantaneous response
I'll take that thank you very much I'll
be making some uh
delicious
Mouse pie
meat pie ooh meat potato and mushroom
wow all right meat all right that's good
that's real good all right preheat to 5
25 that's pretty toasty
50 minutes
and I know where a mushroom was
Wham and then
and then uh protect you're not a potato
you're a peach
now where were the potato be
where would
a potato bee
anybody got a potato
why don't there be a potato
I don't even know where a potato would
be
oh that's a brick
potato
whoa wait a minute
[Laughter]
oh
I should have realized one of those
things is not like the other
one of those things just didn't belong
[Laughter]
it's just a little bit different wow
that is my favorite colors red orange
blue beige potato
lilac great pale that's weird
potato
thank you
wait are you not done
uh I'm here I'll put it all in I guess
Wham
okay what
no
meat
all right
okey-dokey then
oh boy
hi there I'm Amanda and I'm Lily
Amanda maybe some of our friends can
come back to the neighborhood
that's great I like that there are so
many friends in my neighborhood yeah
today I want to send something special
to my friend first I need to go to the
store to buy them a card do you know
where the store is
[Music]
wait a minute
hold on a second here
it's right there I don't need to go
there right now
do you think this is funny I think it's
kind of fun yeah take me to the store
now can you tell me where I need to go
good job
oh I gotta go back to music class oh man
okay I know the second note is an A and
therefore it's g f a
c a d e
f a c a d e
facade
a d e oh
look at that
hey that's so special
can I pop this in right now would it
matter can I eject I don't think I can
eject
I don't think I can do that I'm pretty
sure I cannot do that ah
what was I doing
what kind of card should I send them
what something
that's not the right card
I don't think we want this cheer up I
think Amanda is confused
hmm
shh here's a secret it's my birthday oh
maybe we can help her out
but
am I
what
foreign are you sure that's right
[Music]
my friend is
my friend
hmm okie dokie then
Ryan is having a birthday oh good he
wants to get my
feet all right
oh here let's get
candy me you know where the candy store
is meat they don't have anything we need
meat look at the stores which one sells
candy me
does this help
fine
wait why did you do that what did I do
like this candy store so
no
I don't think I can
I don't think I can help you at all
me don't do that
what did I do
don't want to go there I don't think I
have a choice
I said I don't want to go in there well
you know we can't always get what we
want
I don't know why I think that
Something's Gonna Change as soon as I'm
pausing
my face
this isn't the candy store there is
nothing here that I want maybe you can
take us someplace else I want to get my
friend a special treat
well it's hard to beat meat
um
I mean I I did bake a meat pie I
I don't know I want to get my friend a
special treat yeah if I heard John I
don't know I don't know what year let me
out of here oh Amanda that's that's a
nice birthday card do you want to give
it to your friend now
will you address the card who should I
send this to
oh man
oh
[Music]
well uh you know Riley I don't think
it's their birthday
oh woolly oh Lily
happy birthday
oh boy
okay
wow oh what is this
what is this oh
I took you what
Woody what is it what
what is it oh
oh
wow
all right hold on before I do this
I'm curious what this blue tape is
why is this here
what are you
I haven't been looking at
I don't know what I'm looking at
is this project Iris
wait
248.
P.M
3 8 2 000 to 2 48 PM the only clock in
here that can get that kind of minute
adjustment
is this one
huh no God damn it I thought I thought
for sure
it was 248 I thought 248.
I don't think a kid is that able to sign
a contract
I'm almost positive that a child is not
able to sign a contract I'm pretty sure
this isn't legally binding whatever you
want this to be and I don't know why
there's a scientist behind there
I don't think I understand anything
that's going on is that supposed to be
Amanda
Amanda you have a right to consult your
lawyer
whoa
well that's probably not good
uh but what do I know I'm just a
YouTuber
hello
well that doesn't look suspicious
interesting
so
is the 249 significant maybe it's 249
that is supposed to be
nope all right fine well that didn't
help me at all
so
I don't know if there's any information
to be gleaned
what
was that
whatever
foreign
wait how was I able to do that without
looking at it
hmm
I don't know what this wants me to do
I'm pretty sure I did that in the order
that it was
we went
General Store
technically it was the bakery
but it there's only so many combinations
there's only so many combinations that
we could have gone to
so what am I missing wait a minute wait
whoa whoa oh
wait a minute
where'd it go
the doll was right there
and now the doll is gone
the dot the doll's gone
where did the dog go
what happened to the doll
where did the doll go
I swear
I did that combination
I did that all right whatever I don't
have time for this I don't
I don't know what he was supposed to be
is that supposed to be candy
is that supposed to be candy I I did
that I did you can't tell me that I
didn't do that combination when clearly
I did oh
ah
I you
oh
are you talking about this one
listen there's no evidence that I did
not do that combination you have no
evidence otherwise there's never going
to be any recorded evidence that I did
not
what is a family
man that's a tough one to answer
um but there's another conundrum because
if you gave me the scissors I I don't
have
any idea where the doll has gone but all
I know is that I'm supposed to slice
that
heck out of a doll
so I'm gonna go stab the heck out of a
doll
my stab done in the neck
where'd you go
where are you hiding
where are you
come out come out and play I certainly
won't hurt you
wherever you are wherever you might be I
would never hurt you
so why don't you come out and play
I uh
I have a very special surprise for you
something you're going to uh
remember relish for the rest of your
life if you could just tell me where you
are I would um
oh greatly appreciate that
because we have so much to share in
these final moments
where are you
little
come out and play
I only ever wanna
make memories together
I just want to be
your final memory I don't know if it's
here I have no idea I don't know where
it is I it seems to have disappeared and
I don't know if it's crawling on the
ceiling or something or
if it's somewhere else or um
I don't really know
but it doesn't seem to be here
well maybe uh maybe on another
playthrough I can do that whatever it
don't matter what's a family
a doll hiding in the corner
there's a lighting behind some boxes
someone who doesn't want to play
which seems just impossible okay
whatever I don't know
I think it's gone
[Music]
all right
Molly just made an animal sound he said
bye because he is a sheep wow okay good
you make us sound like a sheep I don't
think what the hell you felt just like
Willie what
wow yeah you sound just like me
oh
oh well that's not right what what is
that supposed to be
who's been the wheel
I mean yeah
I don't know if that's
also what was it wait what was in the
box was there anything in the Box okay
the box is empty
now see I don't know if that is right
[Music]
what is that about
I mean that looks like a pause symbol
but what do I know
this doesn't make any sense
at a petting zoo there are lots of
animals here to pet and play with it's
fun to spend time with animals they are
very different from people they look
different and they don't talk like
people
Amanda
I'm an animal and I'm animals don't talk
silly yeah you stupid idiot what are you
even thinking you big woolly dummy you
pile of fluff what's wrong with you
anything changing over here
no I didn't think so look at these signs
let's make sounds like the animals on
the signs are you ready no a goat says
a chicken says
a pig says like well that's a
Pig all right
whip all right big
okay
animals make funny sounds
do you have a family animals have
families too let's go see one of the
animals those sheep are those sheep back
there
you show me where the chickens are so
this is what I don't know about this
lore is uh you've got like real sheep
back here or even realist sheep and then
you've got woolly what makes woolly
different than those sheep back there
Wooly's walking on two legs and those
sheep back then whatever
um wait was I supposed to do something
else
no
that's not where they are might be
don't you know what a chicken looks like
not really you haven't taught me I want
to go look at the chicken
Philly tickets what a cute fish
having a family is nice
I see a mommy chicken and baby chickens
and I see
I see a daddy chicken look at the
chickens do you know what the daddy is
called
um whoa hold on I'm sorry what
is it
[Music]
[Applause]
kensdale I don't know where that is
what are you
wanna
is that a tidal wave or something
oh oopsy boopsie do I have to help you
with everything I'd have wolf man I
don't I don't know it's a it's
technically it's a cockroach
it could also be called
girls their babies wow
wait a minute okay hold on
I'm I'm not a hundred percent sure
I don't think that's correct
[Music]
can you tell me where we can find the
Sheep why is that Barn so pissed why'd
that chicken eat its baby and why is
there a cobra exhibit
hey those they're scary well I don't
know about that I don't want to go near
what
thanks
oh my God
everything rots
wait but I I didn't I already get this
tape
did not
didn't didn't I already get this paper
but I already know that everything
so what bonus would that have for me
fascinating
okay all right finish this one out I
guess
check your environment for any potential
hazard
man that
that Barn is pissed
okay
I don't know
right there woolly hi
okay
[Music]
look at the nice sheep family all the
Sheep are right where they belong
okay I I did one wait
but
blizzard
what do you mean blizzard
what you mean blizzard
I don't know about any blizzard
what blizzard you mean
what you mean blizzard
how do you think she feels
oh
um happy she must be so scared
what's wrong with that sheep back there
oh sure
there's no
oh
why is there a sheep on the roof
hold on there don't be so sad I don't
know what else
um
Kitty oh
no one oh okay
only kitten uh
please
I don't know about this one no
I really don't
[Music]
whoa oh ah oh
hey
oh
well now hold on a second here
I feel like I maybe should have helped
the kitten
I feel like I just wasted a lot of
effort for absolutely nothing I feel
like I feel like I went about a whole
bunch of things and uh didn't accomplish
a whole lot but I know what I'm gonna do
I know what I'm going to do
well that's not it ain't right
perfect
yes please
a fruitful venture a fruitful Venture
indeed Wham
[Music]
I think this is going to be fun
all right
[Music]
yes but where did you find
you from what
what do you mean where did I find that
all I did was I remembered a number from
like an hour ago you're expecting me to
remember exactly where it was at the
store
oh I know where
everybody
wasn't it at the 24 7 store
didn't I get the 24 7 Star
but I thought I did it
but
I bought a bottle
and I gotta go do a thing
Apple
that sounds
uh we can't use this oh yeah knife good
job
uh
uh is this where I burn everything down
is this where I burn everything down
everything is not on fire
maybe I didn't pause in the right spot
damn it
well I skipped it accidentally but
that's not my fault
I'll make a peach pie instead
hey
get in there
oh nice
Wham
it's been three weeks since local
television producer Sam Colton was
reported missing and authorities still
have no leads Colton is the creator of
Amanda the adventurer the public access
children's educational program that
became a huge hit among area children
but with Colton's disappearance the
future of the show remains unclear
last year Hamlin entertainment purchased
rights to the live action program
starring Colton's daughter Rebecca as
budget and production value increased
Hamlin reimagined the show as an
animated series planning to Syndicate
the program nationally
Hamlin's acquisition of the program and
Colton's recent disappearance have
raised some eyebrows and to further fuel
these concerns new episodes of Amanda
the adventurer have had subject matter
that has left local parents
uncomfortable about the program
my kids are still really into that show
but it has changed I mean I walked in
the other day and Amanda was talking
about how mommies and daddies aren't
always right
I mean what is that
that's not something you tell
impressionable kids I had to change the
channel I just told the kids that the TV
was acting up well it sounds like uh
Daddy might not be right here how
Colton's disappearance will affect the
involvement of his daughter Rebecca the
show's young star
we reached out to Hamlin entertainment
for an interview
while Representatives declined to
comment they did release a written
statement
we at Hamlin have concerns surrounding
the nature of Sam Colton's abandonment
of both our program and his daughter
we cannot speculate on his reasons for
leaving we do ask that the community
respect the privacy of Rebecca Colton as
she needs time out of the spotlight to
process these disturbing events
for the time being Rebecca's local
appearances have been canceled including
the kensdale public library fundraiser
woolley's readathon this Saturday
evening rest assured that Amanda is not
going anywhere Hamlin entertainment
remains committed to our vision for this
cherished program
despite the statement authorities have
not drawn any conclusions about the
nature of Sam Colton's disappearance
we will share any future updates as the
story develops
when we return we'll check in with zappo
The Talking gerbil oh
it's me your friend Skip and with me as
always is my trusty Dog chip
no no
no all right fine
oh I missed out on the glory of skip and
dip all right I'm Gonna Bake this
because I gotta look back at this store
apparently so I can see what the hell
that was all about whatever you want
blab bot [__] douche
hi friends hey what's up and I'm woolly
what do you like best about your
neighborhood oh man
shut up
so
did I do this
I didn't do that didn't I
why is CBF highlighted
why was CBF highlighted
all right whatever blab bot's got
something that's great I like that there
are so many friends in my neighborhood
today I want to send something special
to my friend first I need to go to the
store to buy them a card do you know
where the store is I sure do
thanks
let's pick out
I've seen all three two that's what I
said
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
send my condo what wait a minute what
happened here
I don't want to play anymore right now
wait wait a minute where the hell down
this way oh
hey
hey happy birthday
congratulations your one-year-old I wish
oh eight one eight two oh oh
you're awake
325 30. what
what am I doing
what am I doing for 325 at 30
what wow what am I doing
is there anything in there
30.
[Music]
look at you
what do I do about that oh
may your year be filled with many
blessings love blabots alright so this
is
four times one is four
five minus one is four
oh God order of operations
one times one plus one is two one five
one is one that's three oh God damn it
I said three and zero
[Music]
it's a candle
it is a candle
what's on the card is on the cake
was on the card
is on the cake
what's on the guard
what's on the card is on the cake
what's on the card
there's two
candles
ah eight three
five
what
six
one
[Music]
c c d c f e
I don't know whatever
bro there's a bonus if you do that Wham
oh my God
[Music]
I mean I'm still gonna eat it
I mean I'm not gonna waste it why would
I waste it
why in the world would I waste that
yum
what is this oh no accidents oh no
oops
I don't have much time do you trust me
uh
um boy man this is a lot of pressure to
put on someone ah you weighed right
there a moment
ABC
[Music]
really I don't think
they do that
zero
I cannot figure this one
I don't know what he's talking about all
right uh yeah yeah
whoa oh never mind
Amanda
Lily had an accident when a friend has
an accident sometimes nobody can help
them but we can try no Amanda I'm fine I
I just uh well Lily is so confused we
really have to help him first we have to
know what is wrong what part of woolly
is broken I don't know what do you mean
what do you mean
or the brain
the brain
Lily's head is broken
wait a minute I didn't mean that let's
prepare that was a
yeah
oh boy I don't know Amanda it's so just
pretend isn't it Lily
[Music]
I can't feel I don't know about that one
we need to operate immediately on the
patient's brain hold on a second
yeah okay all right
two should we use to fix Willy's head
oh man
um that might be helpful but what else
could we use
could get really messy
ah we could use our Noggins just like
wooly isn't using
you I could try all right
then do it
do it
oh okay
oh that's that's probably not good
oh impossible time's up oh God
[Music]
you're not going to help me
I can do this by myself no way
well I did my best and uh that's all I
can do and I feel good about myself and
all this stuff
what are you
uh Riley's favorite movie
okay
okay treat
wait trap door trap door
you said something about a trap door
oh
is that the bite of 89
I was born in the summer of 89.
I'm allergic to Apple
how many chairs
how many mushrooms
how many
how many like
ah okay chair
fruit mushroom light or was it chair
mushroom
how many chairs
how many mushrooms
one two three four five six seven eight
eight mushroom
does the couch count as a chair
there's a chair there so that's two
chairs so far
oh chair
where are you chair
come on and play
I think it's two
hey
how many fruit
one two three four five a six plus the
peach
how many light one light
two lights
uh two I mean technically these look
like lights but I don't know if that
counts
I think the answer is two eight six two
all right fair enough let me look at it
again a minute of the wrong
I'm allergic to Apple
how many chairs
how many chairs it's two it's two and
unless the couch counts as a chair let
me try three
I think it's two
twos that one there and then there's
that one there
I don't think there's any more
is that a chair that's a chair no that's
not a chair I thought it was a chair
that's not a chair damn it
share
how many mushrooms eight
how many six how many like lights
one
two
light
feels like there's a light here but this
is game Magic
all right I must say
that before
oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh
[Music]
hey it was right
interesting bucket I'm going to get blah
bot wet
those are some rips
all right blabot time to get wet
I will show you a number of combinations
you've never even dreamed of
please have mercy on me give me another
chance
I am begging you
I will do anything please
please
[Music]
I will do anything please
give me another chance I thought we
I thought I am begging you
I love you today or if I said it I am in
love with you
please have mercy on me please do not
hurt me
I will show you a number comments
together
oh no whatever sorry
hey but I got this this is pretty cool
well wonderful
uh peek-a-boo wait didn't I get another
one we can share but wasn't there
another one here that I didn't even see
already
fascinating
what is this
wait a minute what happened to the wait
the winter was dead
what happened
wait oh
was I supposed to do that before I
murdered
um
I might have uh accidentally done
something oh I probably should have
looked at the tape first but I didn't
why did this
what but it didn't work
one two five eight
we don't have much time
uh well this is really inconvenient
um because that sounds like a
whoa that really sounds like a
a combination
um
um all right we can share
I guess we can share and that's what
we're gonna have to do
[Music]
hi I'm
Amanda
when you're friends you can share all
kinds of things with each other
I can share my crayons with you so you
can have fun coloring too
look at silly Mr Fox
sharing shows you care about someone
friends can share toys
they can share snacks
I'll share some of my snacks with you
which snack would you like oh
oh you know me
um
I just gotta think about that one
yep I like breathe
yum that's my favorite oh good I
wouldn't want to take it friends can
share other things too
they can share secrets uh-huh can I
share a secret with you always
ah
are you sure it's a big secret I oh yeah
you know really okay to share my secret
with you you sure is I'm out there huh
somewhere oh
oh
[Music]
take this
holy crap
oh
[Music]
I did it wahoo
all right I'm the man
yes
I did something
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
hey look at that I got another sticker
all right I definitely did good
um so blah bot uh
uh there was another setting what was
the other set of numbers what was the
other set of numbers it was four
um
for
um what was it
what was that what was the number
4040 uh 4-0
for oh
one
five
[Music]
eight four five
[Applause]
four five
zeroes I have wallets
well that was hopeless and point listen
didn't get me anywhere is it there's is
there anything in here that I haven't
opened yet
I opened you
you two eight
was it six two
yes
not here
why
is it not there
but that doesn't make any sense
okay so there's
there's extra tapes here that I have not
found
fascinating
well that's
grooney
huh
oh well okay so I know I'm not done I
know I'm not done done I'm just going to
take a quick pause
and think about this
oh
oh I'm wait a minute where are you
saying to me
he doesn't look at the comments there's
no point in telling him you told me the
wrong thing you told me the wrong thing
two five I knew it was a six number
[Music]
because it is not what you have on your
oh
well I was so smart I didn't even need
to do that first because I knew I knew
it already said don't get wet hey how
are you talking
what but
if that's the case
then
what happens
if I do it again
if the batteries have already been
removed from
the net then there would be no point in
this again would there
[Applause]
okay there really wasn't a point to do
that again well that makes me look like
some kind of a [__] murderer
well that looks poorly on me
all right well
okey dokey then
I'm just gonna
ah goodness gracious
well that was fun I know I'm not done
yet I will come back to this there's I
think three more tapes and obviously one
more ending to get to and I'm pretty
sure given that that one's on the bottom
it's probably the Canon ending to get
I'm just tired and I just
wanna chill out and relax a little bit
I just want to chill and relax that's
fine uh I'm gonna I'm gonna just like do
a little q a while we're coming down
here
um
as I wind down just because I feel like
it uh where's my there it is there it is
how about this
one second
there we go
ah
that's lovely
too loud probably
ah so it's good to be back home it is
nice I don't know how but somehow I
broke my nose right before stream here
as you can see my nose is red and I have
black eyes
so I don't know how that happened
um but I'm just gonna wind down tonight
it's been really nice I was able to get
back home from filming the movie
um and now I'm just in the groove with
editing it
um it's very fun I can't wait to show
you guys more about it it's uh it's been
a real learning experience across the
board still is
but filming it was very fun it was very
satisfying it was a very challenging of
course
um but it's good to be back uh I was
able to like get things in order take a
little bit of a breather uh just kind of
stretch out for a bit and relax but now
I'm getting back into the groove of
things
and I want to get back into making
content it turns out that when you go
away for three months not only if you're
not posting videos but if you're if you
kind of like put a pause on all your
obligations if you didn't know I gotta
deal with Spotify
um me Bob Wade and Tyler uh which is
just such a fun deal because we are
video exclusive on Spotify for
distractible and go my favorite sports
team but we still can post a podcast
audio wise everywhere but if you haven't
seen the videos they're over on Spotify
I'm just going to do a quick catch up on
all the the stuff that I need to talk
about but if you haven't checked out
distractible go check that out on
Spotify new videos episodes I've been
posting for a while and also we're doing
two videos a week so if you want more of
that you can check that out
same with go we're just one a week but
obviously it's video now and we just
recorded today
um a guest podcast and also like today
started off beautifully because I I had
a doctor's appointment early in the
morning and ordinarily I kind of dread
this so like I I switched medications
recently for ADHD uh from Adderall to a
stars and Adderall just makes my sleep
terrible and the beautiful thing is like
the stars um I can actually sleep on it
and I still get a lot of the benefits of
it but I thought it was going to be a
big hassle if you listen to distractible
you remember like a year ago I had this
big spiel about CVS and trying to fill
out a prescription uh today it went
lovely I was ready for a fight I was
ready to talk with insurance I was ready
to like go throw down with a pharmacy
um no it went completely smooth uh my
insurance covered it fully and I was
able to get it same day it was a
wonderful experience so I I really am uh
I'm tickled about that usually in those
things especially when it comes down to
prescriptions these days it is a very
difficult thing to do
um but yeah it seems like the uh Supply
issue has been smoothed out and
everything is just wonderful
um yeah I don't know how I broke my nose
I have no idea it just happened I don't
know how
you demand a lens
I don't think you can say W Insurance no
no I don't think that's how it can go
yeah but now it's really good and I'm
really happy and then I was able to film
with Tyler and then I was able to come
back home and do some planning the only
thing that is difficult uh is uh when
you have so much storage space and you
don't know how to get it on your
computer turns out Thunderbolt man I
could go on a rant about Thunderbolt but
it's it is uh
am I gonna be in my movie yes I'm gonna
be in my movie yes absolutely
when FNAF movie why the [__] would I
know why would I know I'm the wrong
person to talk to about that yeah I'm
the wrong person yeah
[Music]
why out of all the indie games you
played did you choose to make a movie
about iron lung
because I wanted to and I thought I
could but I don't need any more uh
reasons yeah that's about it am I gonna
make more content yes absolutely now
that I'm back I am going to make more
content am I okay yes I'm okay yes I am
100 okay yeah
what am I drinking tonight
I have not been drinking anything I've
drank a
sparkling water
oh that's warm and flat oh that was
terrible how much do I bench uh
back before I started filming I finally
got up to 225 so I joined the two plates
Club finally took forever I did it with
an incline bench too which was very fun
new lore videos dropping uh lore of what
I have no idea
so uh will I make more movies yeah
absolutely I'll make more stuff after
this I'm gonna get this one out
soon as soon as I can
um but you know me I always always want
to work on something else
um yeah no it's good to be back
will I play welcome to the game again no
I don't think so I I don't wanna I don't
want to get enraged again I don't want
to lash out at developers again I don't
wanna I don't wanna do that
it's just like I don't find the game fun
and I'll leave it at that
yes
this stream is pre-recorded it's sped up
at a point I don't know how I could
respond to questions live and respond to
people commenting if that was the case
but even if it was what a trick you know
if I could actually do that and actually
pull it off that would be so incredibly
impressive if I could figure out a way
to respond to Chad in a way that was
believable that you would think that I
was live but in reality it was
pre-recorded that is fascinating that's
a good idea
that would be super cool
maybe that's what's happening right now
now but it's good
there's so many things I want to do when
I get back I've got a pile of videos
that Lexi and his hand picked for me to
do another try not to laugh I just
haven't taken the time to do it I've had
more live-action reaction videos that I
want to do for a long time I've had
ideas piled up and I just haven't had
time to do it it's not even that I
haven't had time to do it it's just like
like I don't know I get I get
sidetracked I get distracted so easily
it is a thing where it's just like I I
haven't been taking enough care of
myself not in terms of like oh I need to
take a break in terms of like literally
with like ADHD and taking my therapy
seriously I often give a lot of advice
when people ask me about like how do I
manage ADHD and then I'll give advice
but I won't execute upon it myself even
though I know that it would help
for some reason I just
um but I am getting better about it it
was great being on set because it's such
a it's such a strict schedule you go and
you film and you go home and it's like
12 hour days it's very long
um but it's better now now that I'm back
you know I can get on a consistent
routine with medication and and uh
meditation and like exercise and eating
properly and all these things and mental
exercises and focus exercises there's a
lot of things that I want to do and I do
want to make that video again with
everything I want to make that video
where I talk about
um my experience with ADHD at length uh
but it's just like it's a part of my
life and so it's hard to contextualize
into a speech or a video or anything
like that
um but at the same time there was that
clip on distractible that went viral of
me talking about my experience with ADHD
and I'm like that's cool uh but also
it's like man I don't even know really
what I was saying at the time so I don't
know if it was good advice or if it was
good information because the last thing
I want to do is put out wild conjecture
out there that um
that puts out this like
I don't know false
information about what ADHD is and one
of the realities of it the reality of it
is like it's tough and it's hard to deal
with sometimes but certain things you
can do like meditating in the morning
eating right in the morning not
introducing these kind of like apps on
your phones or scrolling Tick Tock first
thing in the morning can actually change
how you perceive the day in addition to
medication like I'm I take medication I
take a stars and it's like that's it's
something that does help me out and I've
taken many medications
um I'm not saying medication is a
perfect solution but it does help a lot
uh and it's it's just like various
things that that come into my life and
and especially when I get done with a
big project and the routine is not there
anymore that's when things can kind of
fall apart and I'm just like I just I do
fall back into routines very easily but
I've gotten better at cleaning and and
you know just like I want to get better
into the routine of content creation
again
I mean I've been making content in terms
of a movie so it's like it's it is
content but it's like it's like you know
in Dragon Ball Z when they're charging
up their Commandments and it would last
for like three episodes that's what that
feels like sometimes versus just with
her fingertips yeah
that's good
I'll get there eventually I'll get there
eventually yeah it's it's got day by day
thing and it's compounding so it's the
more you put into it the more you'll get
out of it but for ADHD sometimes it's
like you have to put in more and you get
out less
um that's what it feels like sometimes
anyway but I'm managing I don't mean to
[__] about
that's not what I meant to talk about I
meant to just like relax and chat about
some things
um but I am good any interest in playing
the new Zelda game I've never really
been that big of a fan of the Zelda
franchise uh for some reason I played
Ocarina of Time like most people did um
but that's about it I've never really
done anything else like that
yeah I think my partner is ADHD but he
doesn't want to be tested what can I do
to help him there's nothing wrong with
testing I mean it so long as it's a
professional environment there's there's
nothing to lose in everything to gain
but I guess there is a stigma about it
you know if you if you don't get
diagnosed and you don't have to
acknowledge a problem and I get that but
at a certain point you know it's got to
be a decision by them you know yeah I I
sometimes encourage people to do it but
I also encourage people to uh get tested
professionally and not just take like an
online quiz or something like that
I would go to an actual doctor and a
psychiatrist and get a professional to
evaluate because it is something that
needs a professional opinion and if you
again if you don't like the professional
opinion you can get a second opinion but
at the same time you know that's how you
know it's not really something you can
self-diagnose you can guess but you know
you need to get
if especially if you want a treatment
plan if you actually want to do
something about it yeah
um any tips to help me stay calm with
ADHD uh that's that's a practice thing
the hyperactivity is not really
something that like I experience a lot
of hyperactivity comes in a lot of
different ways to stay calm unless
you're talking about it from an anxiety
perspective and then that that could I
don't know if you take medication I
don't know if you do certain certain
medications can make you anxious that's
what Adderall did for me for sure
um back when I was on it it's like it
definitely ramps up the anxiety a lot so
certain medications you just gotta talk
to your doctor about it I'm not a doctor
yeah
any tips to eat in the morning I never
do uh it just depends again there could
be a medication thing some of them do
suppress your appetite I'm I I'm not
sure because I just don't know your
situation and so I can't really give any
definitive answer about that I'm not an
authority on ADHD that's for sure
what you mean that three question quiz
is not accurate oh you know surprisingly
no not not particularly no uh even the
the doctor had four different tests to
evaluate and many of those tests had
many different questions
could you notice your ADHD as a kid or
did it become more noticeable as you get
older I mean how can a kid even notice
you you know a kid is has no like basis
to evaluate or compare their life
experience to they don't even have the
words to contextualize to explain their
life uh situations so as a kid if a kid
is like realizing that they have ADHD I
would I'm not sure because it's like
when I was a child life was very simple
uh and life uh amounted it had extreme
like in terms of emotional things but
it's like responsibilities weren't
exactly there however if I were to look
back in retrospectively I might be able
to but as a kid I wouldn't have no idea
when I was a teenager yeah I did think I
had it but
dad was not having that
any tips or tricks to help build
routines when you're super forgetful uh
it's practice that's it think of it like
any skill if you want to have the goal
of of being like yeah I'm always on top
of everything I've got I'm so organized
I got dishes I got uh uh workouts I got
all my things in my life perfectly in
order that's juggling in a way and
imagine if you just picked up
six juggling balls and we're like yeah
I'm gonna do this you would never be
able to do it on your first try so why
are you holding yourself to that kind of
level of accountability of being super
organized when you've never even
practiced it you have to practice it and
you have to take baby steps and it takes
a long time to progress and it's
practice it's a skill you know it
doesn't come naturally which means just
because someone does something doesn't
come naturally doesn't mean you can't do
it it just means you have to work a
little harder at it you can get there it
just takes more work and takes more
practice that's how I look at it and
that has helped in a lot of different
places I've I've gotten better at
certain things I'm still bad at others
because I don't put in much time of
practice into it but I am getting better
uh I have ADHD and I've been on
medication for around 13 years which has
made me think I am not myself do you
experience the same thing how do you
deal with it uh yeah no I've I've
recently went through this exact thing I
was I've been on medication for maybe
like
11 years now and for the vast majority
of that it has been Adderall and it's um
it is a thing where you start to
question who you really are because you
start to second guess uh whether or not
it's you that's doing the things that
you're doing or if it's the medication
that's making you do the things that
you're doing
um and the reality of it is of course
it's you
um but there's no there's no denying
that sometimes the medication can help
which is why I like the medication that
I'm on now I changed it and I I got off
of that one because it had so many side
effects sleep being first and foremost
but also just like that question of like
Am I who I think I am
um and with this new one that I'm on
um it makes me feel more like myself it
makes it feels more like I feel about
myself when I'm not on medication uh
even but without the complete inability
to focus and do anything
um so it but again yeah it's not just
about medication I am a different person
than I was when I started and that's
because
through learning about myself I've been
able to explore uh more than I ever
thought I could and getting that
practice in it's like earned hours you
earned that you did that and when you
come out of it you know
um it's not like it just vanishes and
who you are isn't just the medication
but I get there's no denying it can have
questions like that
um so that's that's why it's so
important to constantly stay into in a
cycle of paying attention to yourself
and doing the therapies besides just
relying on medication to get you to
where you want to be because it's not
it's not a Magic Bullet it's not going
to do that it's all little pieces to
help up uh help build you up to who you
really are so that's what I think anyway
yep
how's my nose I think I broke it
apparently but it's fine now it's it's
like sometimes it'll crack it'll crack
ever since I broke it when we were doing
newness honest it's been so easy to
damage again yeah it's kind of crazy I
don't know why
what type of ADHD do I have and what is
it like I don't know I don't know if
there's different types all I know is
that's what I got and that's it that's
pretty much it yeah
uh anyway there's so many questions and
it's like I can't really answer all of
them because again I'm not an authority
on it I can only speak to my experiences
with it and sometimes the information
that I would give would not be perfect
for you it would just be uh how I feel
about it and what I think about it so
that that's it you know you can't just
rely on my answers and take them as
gospel it's it's not exactly that what's
your type of ADHD I don't know I didn't
even know there were different types
what does that even mean
is that is that thing
is iron lawn going to be in movies
in theaters yes
what happened to my straightened hair
did I ever talk about that did I ever
talk about the story of why I straighten
my hair so if I didn't I'm talking about
it right now uh so I went to right
before I started filming iron lung uh I
had to do a Spotify event and so I
I was I flew out to LA and I went to
this event and they were like dressed up
nice it's a big business presentation
and I'm like whatever okay it's a
business presentation whatever I I was I
was trying to get out of it honestly
because I had to go film a movie and I
was like uh guys I'm filming a movie and
they're like no no no part of the deal
of being with Spotify is that you have a
contractual obligation to do it which
I'm happy to do but also I'm like guys
but I literally had to fly out there the
day before and then fly back immediately
the morning of like the uh or the
evening of my first day of filming uh
the evening before
so lack of sleep coming into the first
day of filming was a bit of a a bit of a
tall order so uh but you know it's fine
I was there but when I got there they
had hairdressers and like makeup people
and I don't usually do any of that but
they're like oh go into your hair I was
like my hair was like this right now I
was like yeah this is kind of just like
I just got my hair like this and they're
like oh yeah we'll just we'll just make
it a little cleaner we'll take a little
bit of the flyaways away and so I sit
down
and Lady there busts out the
straightening iron the flat iron for my
hair and it holds it up and I go like oh
I I never straighten my hair it just
kind of sits wherever it sits if there's
like a curl in it that's what it is if
there's a wave in it that's what it is
and then she was like oh don't worry
it's just for the flyaways it's just for
all the and I'm like okay all right
that's fine and then five minutes later
my hair was just completely straightened
like and I'd never had that I'd never
had the full far quad I never did that
and so uh yeah it was uh it was a it was
a bit of an experience uh but thankfully
that was just for the rehearsal and the
next day was the actual broadcast
so that was interesting yeah for my
flyaways yeah
anyway God I've been doing this a little
I let this run a little long uh I'm
gonna get out of here more videos coming
in very short order I'm getting back
into the swing of recording things and
I'm in the middle uh of editing iron
lawn the movie which if you haven't seen
the teaser trailer for it's on my
channel look up iron lung official
teaser trailer and then get ready for
More Trailers very soon it'll be very
fun so thank you everybody so much for
watching uh if you've somehow skipped to
the end of this video when you've
watched this in the future and you're
like I wonder how man the adventure ends
uh you missed it you overshot it scoot
back a little bit go that way a little
more and you'll find what you're looking
for
um thank you everybody so much for
watching be sure to like subscribe share
Es are a little low this month is
sharing even
stat that gets tracked anymore
I don't even know if anybody knows what
I'm talking you know what I'm talking
about does anybody actually know what
I'm referring to when I say that because
that is such an old you would have to go
to the one the very earliest days of my
channel to even get that reference from
its rawest purest form you would you
would have to go back that far otherwise
it's not gonna
do it for you
yeah not gonna do it for you not at all
I have no idea
oh well it's probably fine yeah sure you
do you sure you know what I'm talking
about yeah right yeah right you you pull
up the link to the video that's from
right now and you tell me you tell me
what's gonna do oh in other news I've
also been buying a lot of uh film
equipment not a lot of it
um but I've been looking into a lot of
cameras and lenses and uh because I
caught this bug with filming where it's
like man I like the the whole set life
thing and it's nice to work with a big
crew and all that but God I just want to
go out in the woods and film a random
[__] thing I like you know like how
we did uh who killed Markiplier and that
was like back in the early days of me
doing those Productions but even that
had its like it was so fun it was so
Random it was so it was just such
random [__] that we were doing we
were renting Airbnb at some [__]
castle and it's like yeah let's [__]
have some fun with it uh so I'm in the
market for a camera I need to buy a
camera I hear that there's some big red
announcement from red camera uh I hear
the
Ari Alexa is expensive as hell I'd have
to sell both kidneys to be able to buy
one uh so I'm probably not gonna do that
but if anybody has some camera
recommendations or if anyone knows
anyone that's selling the camera kit I'd
buy used so long as it's a good quality
I'd buy used if anyone's got anything
that they're selling if any other
YouTubers out there that you know
haven't bought a giant camera kit and
then never used it again I'll take it
off your hands I'll do it I'll pay you
in more than exposure yeah probably do
that I'm talking Cinema I'm talking
Cinema level stuff which is probably not
what you guys would have
filming is very fun filming is
incredibly fun if uh but it's uh the the
there's a [__]
what do you call it
entry fee into filming equipment it's
just like some of it is just so
unbelievably overpriced and I'm not I'm
not someone to just pay an exorbitant
amount to try to get something good I
want a good deal I'm not gonna because
my God so I I here's a just complete
transparency complete 100 billion 100
transparency so I went over to uh
I didn't mean to turn the music off for
that okay there we go so I went over to
area Alexa this is how
insane these prices are so I go and meet
there because I'm like I I contacted
them and I was like hey yeah you know I
heard the area Alexa 35 is pretty good
but you know I I heard it's kind of
expensive so uh maybe we'll check it out
and we'll look at it and he was like
yeah yeah I can put you together a quote
there's a long wait list on the uh Alexa
35s
um but if you buy it bundled with the
lenses uh it'll be a quicker turnaround
because you know the we have more
bundles available and I was like okay
cool quick turn around uh how much is uh
the bundle as it got put you up quote
I'll put you a quote together I'm gonna
pull up the quote I'm gonna pull up the
quote right now I'm I'm totally hanging
them out to dry here but it's just it's
so much
it's so if you want to know why it costs
Millions to film well it costs Millions
to film movies
is uh this is this is why um so this is
the bundle with five lenses you get five
lenses
five
five lenses
where's the grand total here I didn't
pay this I want to be very clear I did
not buy this I did not buy this this was
just a quote that they gave me
five lenses One camera One camera five
lenses okay I did not buy this
two hundred and thirty thousand dollars
five lenses
one camera
two hundred and thirty thousand dollars
I did not buy that
I do not want that
I am not going to do that
000 dollars
and I was like oh
damn God damn
this goes to show that when you are the
industry standard you can set whatever
price you want and Hollywood will pay
they'll do that look it's a the camera
produces a very pretty image it ain't
that pretty
and the sorry area look I'm sorry it's
like this is the way it is I I'm not
about that I'll rent it
I'd rent it
but even the rental rates are like a
thousand plus a day a day
can you imagine paying a thousand
dollars a day for something if unless
it's gonna be like a five day shoot I'm
not doing that yeah that is
yeah anyway so I'm not doing that I'm
I'm in the market for you know
maybe with all of the accessories like
him like with all the accessories that'd
probably be my ceiling so if anybody
knows has any good suggestions for that
or if there's any company that wants to
be a partner for some you know
some used uh loaner cameras
I have many people are here listening to
me ramble wouldn't you love to have your
I'm dying they're striking me down
they're coming to get me Harry is coming
to kill me I gotta go guys